computer is a game changer for a team
for a pro for a student the raiders
connected with a community like wi-fi
today kevin martin has the story
so i feel like i could do it if they can
shelby curtis was one of 30 students who
attended the tech tomorrow event at
allegiant stadium that included a tour
as well as a panel discussion with four
distinguished professionals in the
industry inspired me like to strive and
do better don't quit
because they made a long way they
started from when they were young around
my age and i'm young technology is an
ever-changing and growing industry and
the tech tomorrow event which was put on
by the raiders foundation dri and jobs
for nevada's graduates was a way for the
youth to continue to learn and build for
their futures we need to inspire our
young people to really thrive and and to
utilize the tools and resources that we
offer and before the event ended the
students got a huge
a surprise with a wireless mouse and a
brand new laptop computer all 30
students received brand new laptops it
was amazing because
like a computer
i love it it's a good experience and i'm
grateful for all of it because
a computer you could go long ways i
always wanted to have my oprah moment to
be able to distribute something like
that as a surprise and we really did
keep this as a surprise they thought
they were coming here just for a career
panel and a tour which was cool in
itself but then to walk away with the
tools that they need to succeed
even better kevin martin live local now